their people made pawns children
clutching plastic bags men and women who
crossed a continent to flee poverty and
violence now being used as political
tools
I left Venezuela on August 18th I passed
through the jungle I spent six days
there it was a tough experience
something Unforgettable I saw many
people dead in the jungle buses sent by
the state of Texas dumped these 101
Asylum Seekers at the side of the road
in front of the residents of Vice
President Kamala Harris Aid workers say
a baby arrived injured and a man with
diabetes was rushed to the hospital
after his insulin went bad on the
40-hour bus ride Republican Governors
interfering in that process and using
migrants as political pawns is shameful
is reckless and just plain wrong a day
earlier 50 Asylum Seekers had been flown
to Martha's Vineyard Massachusetts the
vacation town popular with Washington's
Elites was given little notice to
prepare volunteers quickly mobilized
finding them food and shelter it
manipulating people who are in very dire
circumstances you know purely for
political Gain Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis took credit for the flights
part of a coordinated effort among
Republican Governors to send migrants to
democrat-led cities some have declared
states of disaster to hasten Aid to the
migrants
and all those people in DC and New York
were beating their chests when Trump was
President saying they were so proud to
be Sanctuary jurisdictions saying how
bad it was to have a secure border the
minute even a small fraction of what
those border towns deal with every day
is brought to their front door they all
of a sudden go berserk and they're so
upset that this is happening and it just
shows you you know their virtue
signaling is a fraud at the southern
border U.S agents encountered about two
hundred thousand migrants in July down
from May's Peak and slightly lower than
this time last year greater numbers of
Asylum Seekers are arriving from Cuba
Nicaragua and Venezuela is
it's not just me but thousands of
Venezuelans who look for ways out of the
country in search of the future more
than anything to be honest so our
families can eat three good meals a day
not to be made political ponds in the
U.S Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera
Washington